as I mentioned in the angle conservative
speech is under assault and one of the
starkest examples is that Marquette
University it's a private Catholic
school in Milwaukee
political science professor John McAdams
was suspended and has been since 2014
when he chastised a graduate instructor
named Cheryl Labonte why she apparently
told a student that she would not
tolerate dissent on the topic of
same-sex marriage during her class on
ethics Marquette says it has the legal
right to suspend McAdams because he
opened a bought a up to threats by
criticizing her by name the case is now
headed to Wisconsin Supreme Court
joining us now to explain further is
professor McAdams himself professor you
have taught for 30 years at Marquette
and it's a Catholic institution and yet
this instructor berated a student who
said basically not all of us agree on
your view on same-sex marriage tell us
that's right
it seemed ironic because Marquette
claims to be a Catholic institution but
I think a lot of your viewers know that
a lot of institutions claim to be
Catholic and fundamentally they're
secular and politically correct didn't
they demand that you prostrate yourself
basically and apologize for this
supposed and wrongdoing and your blog
post we said we're you know we're
basically hardly a university if this is
what we're like if we don't tolerate any
dissent and you refused is that right to
apologize sir that's correct they told
me that they would reinstate me if I
apologized and promised to conform to
Marquette's supposed guiding values
promise to do that of course I think
I've I think I'm more loyal to
Marquette's guiding values than the
administration of Marquette University
but of course this is Stalinist stuff
I'm not going to apologize a hundred and
thirty years I have passed and if less
our research is wrong not a single
professor has lost tenure 130 years but
boy I guess you're you're a big threat
professor because you actually decided
to post
the blog yeah it is ironic I mean
professors have lost tenure but it had
to be for something alike of stealing
money from research funds or or raping a
student it had to be something like that
no professor that anyone knows about has
ever been fired or even suspended for a
blog post but do you feel bad about
I guess hurting the feelings of this
particular student instructor I guess
she got a deal on her tuition well I
think it's unfortunate that she got some
really nasty emails although she got no
threats marchetti's claims she got
threats but she admitted in one of her
own blog post that she'd got on threats
so there so that wasn't good on the
other hand anybody whose misconduct is
revealed by a journalist might get some
unkind responses that's for sure
professor I've been I've been the
receiving end of that we're gonna follow
your case I know the arguments coming up
in just about 10 days or so and thank
you so much for giving us your
perspective on this fight at Marquette